yet another sad example of soft on crime
Insanity in Liberal cities of course
once again out west the low life who
plowed his car into a group of 75 Los
Angeles police recruits he's now free as
a bird despite the fact that police
called injuring 25 Cadets a quote
deliberate attack the 22 year old driver
Nicholas Gutierrez arrested on charges
of attempted murder of a police officer
but deputies let him go because
investigators said they need more time
to present their case to the district
attorney who must file charges within 48
hours after an arrest or release
the suspect uh Jesse I want to go to you
first what do you think well I think CNN
is saying that the SUV mowed down the
cadets not the man I don't understand
why he's out you would know better than
I would judge but why wouldn't they
charge him on a no bail count or at
least seek no bail because now he's out
and these Cadets are all losing Limbs
and now in critical condition it sends
the wrong message and he wasn't drunk so
why was he purposely
targeting his car against police I mean
this sounds like a war on cops right
here and it doesn't surprise me this is
happening in Los Angeles County and
tonight on Jesse Waters prime time we're
going to have the sheriff from Los
Angeles County on to explain what the
hell is happening here because this
isn't good and I'm just waiting for
Democrats to say something because
during the election we heard about how
much they loved law enforcement that's
all you heard and then the minute the
election ends someone tries to kill 25
law enforcement officials and no one
even makes a statement about this this
is a pretty big story judge they're
calling it a deliberate attack do you
think they're having trouble getting
into his mind to show it was intentional
I spoke to the DA's today
and um they could have charged him with
a crime
that crime would have been a bailable
offense
what they're doing is they're putting
together the evidence to see
how far they can go these guys are very
ethical you're not finding people who
are DA's out there saying yeah we're
going to get them look at what they did
no they're listening to the law they're
analyzing the law I love the sheriff I
think the sheriff's a great guy the
statutes are very clear they've got to
know what they're dealing with in terms
of the driver before they can charge so
the charges unlike me for take to take
this stance you know what right but with
any attempted murder what is it depends
on whether or not they can attribute
that to his intent what wasn't its
intent what was his condition we're not
saying because we don't yet know got it
let it go can I ask a question though
because you know the reports were that
he was charged with attempted murder of
a peace officer and then released later
that night at 9 49 pm
um there's no charge right now right so
they dropped the charge they didn't have
they did that does that affect the case
long term that you dropped the charges
no no no because look what the police do
is the police can make an arrest the D.A
is the one who says yay or nay to the
charge so please can come in you know
until the cows come home with an attempt
to murder and the D.A can say you don't
have it we don't have the evidence you
finish the investigation we'll go for it
there's no charge now so so Jess let me
turn this to you then and judge you may
be able to jump on this as well it would
seem to me though in looking at Los
Angeles that if you're a law enforcement
agency you feel like your burden is much
higher than it was in the past if you
send something on to George gascon and
his office if you don't have those t's
crossed and eyes dotted don't expect a
vigorous prosecution oh I first want to
say that I'm very glad you went to the
judge before me which I rarely say
because you usually completely disagrees
with what I'm about to say but it was
good backup for this but this was a
central issue in the LA mayor's race
which just got called in Rick Rosso who
was running this time around as a
Democrat put crime front and center in
his campaign and Karen bass ended up
winning but she had even shifted her
message on crime to being much more
serious about it after she had a
break-in herself so this is something
that I believe uh mayor elect bass will
be taking incredibly seriously and
especially that it was going after law
enforcement itself I think things are
going to change even though I know that
there's been a lot of disappointment
more on the right than on the left but
even some Democrats about post-election
messaging that there's been a lot of oh
we're not going to do anything
differently I can tell you here in New
York where I voted people heard loud and
clear what happened we lost four
congressional seats because of the Law
and Order messaging Lee zeldin performed
way above anywhere that we would expect
because he put crime front and center so
I I do think there will be changes I'm
glad that you use the word shift
because that's what happened it yeah
they started talking about it Democrats
very late in their campaigns because Jin
sake the former White House secretary
put out the all-call on hey they're
talking about crime and all the ads and
it's killing us she got to talk about
yeah I mean you know the pundits on
their side of the of the aisle were
saying look the house is on fire
somebody go get a hose so yeah they
started talking about it but they didn't
talk about it in the way that was
substantive in terms of how do you deal
with not letting people go
on crimes that you know that you can you
know six months ago would have been a
felony and now they're a misdemeanor but
look at Josh Shapiro right who's the new
governor of Pennsylvania who talked
about crime from day one it was a
centerpiece of his campaign he went
after D.A krasner for instance Gretchen
Whitmer did the same thing it's not all
Democrat it's not it's two got people
who were able to win governorships Josh
Shapiro got over three million votes
it's historic let's leave this here for
right now but we're not going to leave
the audience alone because all you have
to wait is 90 minutes for Jesse Waters
Prime Time
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else